Armageddon game between Anish sorry
Ariane and Magnus
and this game is again still early days
but there have been some uh well there
has been some drama Anish or not a niche
sorry Arian this time has just
sacrificed a piece and he's trying to
get to that black king both of black
snakes are under threat right now going
for magnus's King mm-hmm
oh and we just see the evaluation but a
slide in favor of black and Magnus
jumping in with his Knight it looks like
this operation was not a good idea for
Ariane and we see a bad Bishop again
yesterday in against Nakamura tari was
suffering in the classical game from a
very bad A7 bishop and look at that he
has the same kind of Bishop only from
the right side
yeah that time it was bad Bishop against
good night and it looks like it could be
good night in this game too if black
does get time now for Rook G8 this is a
beautiful piece uh on F4 it might cost
quite a rook okay Aaron slides across
with his Queen but what to do this black
Rook is simply coming a check on F6 can
simply be blocked Rook G7 looks like
one-way counter play right now is Judith
you mentioned one bad piece makes the
whole position bad this bishop is
terrible
well white is in big trouble has to
defend over G2 but also the D3 Pawn is
under attack and it's gonna be taken one
of them
maybe it's is it time to throw a caution
to the wind grab the knights and
oh there's no way to actually activate
the light Square Bishop so
yeah big trouble actually how are you
going to defend the G2 Pawn because if
you step forward with the Rook to F2
then the Knight will grab the H3 pawn
and that is all over for white
well probably with white I would still
try to go King H1 and try to give up the
G2 but I think Magnus will be not so
nice to take that pawn but the four
and that has provoked a capture of a
pawn from Magnus Carlsen Knight exponent
is a check the King has to move now uh
you want to slide in the corner now can
you activate the queen with E4
wow that would be a lovely move just
pushing the queen and pulling forward to
trying to get the queen in the black
queen is however tied down to the
defense of her Rook on d8 so gotta be
slightly careful maybe just still very
good though that Ivanka feels like
there's something in the air for black
that white king is the more vulnerable
of the two
but two threats Paul takes Knight and a
capture on E5 threatened by white
how to deal with them both
maybe you have to give something up to
get something
well there is a way of maybe giving mate
what about the Rook D6 Queen E5 Rook H6
[Music]
37 Knight F4 or G2 mate beautiful Magnus
surely can't resist he loves the queen
sacrifice uh Rook D6 Rook H6 the
question is that after Rook D6 maybe
Queen H4 can be a saver
might be a savior
but uh well Ariane doesn't have too much
time to figure it out and it's magnus's
move will he play Rook D6 no he Retreats
the Knight again very practical decision
okay but a bit of a Grimace on magnus's
face when he went for this night Retreat
Aryan brings this Rook across trying to
explain why didn't he take on it I don't
understand I think he just saw no hope
in that end game 46 and it's uh
it's over the Checkmate without giving
up the queen Magnus is gonna deliver
Checkmate once the White Queen takes on
E5 the black Rook comes to H6 and as
Judith says there's going to be Knight
checks and a forced mate on the board
Magnus looks away he knows he's got it
in the back two minutes is more than
enough to finish this game off
oh Ariana I think he had some chances
earlier but we'll see you check mate
maybe on the board now that's a check
another night check wherever the white
king goes Knight F4
this is over absolutely uh impressive
game by Magnus he really knows how to
level up when he needs to and Magnus
going back to his winning ways do we
think we'll see Ariana allow the
Checkmate on the board
there we go he drops his note back and
all white can do to postpone the
inevitable is oh my God
Magnus was about to make an illegal move
he wanted to checkmate with his Rook but
the Rook was pinned
instead he just swaps Queens first next
move